un bon soir estelle vous êtes place de
la république les manifestants sont ils
rentrés chez eux
oui les manifestants ont désormais à
quitter la place de la république la
dispersion a débuté aux alentours de 18
heures une dispersion a quelque peu
agitée puisque l'on a assisté à des
heurts entre des les forces de l'ordre
et les manifestants à des manifestants
qui sont venus pour dénoncer les
violences policières et le racisme au
sein des forces de l'ordre un petit peu
plus tôt dans la journée ils se sont
tous à genouillé pour rendre hommage
nous ont-ils dit genre de fleur à george
frey de cet américain décédé lors d'une
interpellation musclée aux états unis je
vous propose de les écouter c'est un
signe symbolique qui est transmis dans
le monde entier
pour représenter la posture du policier
qui a tué georges floyd et
depuis c'est un symbole en fait pour
soutenir et
comment dire mais soutenir ce mouvement
en fait de c'est quand même d'avoir
d'obtenir justice on pourra damart pour
toutes les vies qui sont prises lors des
bavures policières etc
et puis
puis on restera là le ton qu'il faudra
jusqu'à ce que jusqu'à ce qui est du
changement et jusqu'à ce que chacun soit
mis sur le même pied d'égalité on attend
que déjà que l'état nous entende
entendre qu'on en a marre de la violence
de la police
de fait la justice nous ignorent ignore
les violences policières et qu'on se
fasse tuer parce qu'on est tous déjà on
est tous déçus un français quel que soit
notre couleur et on veut faire
comprendre que au monde
on est là on est chez nous et qu'à un
moment on n'est pas traité comme tous
les citoyens classique
nous ce qu'on demande vraiment c'est une
justice simplement qu'on reconnaisse
tout les gros qu est ce qui est un très
beau violences policières et que l'état
fasse en sorte de faire son travail
c'est à dire de protéger toute sa
population quelle que soit sa couleur et
ses croyances et tout ce qu'on demande
voilà pour les revendications sachez
aussi à que le groupuscule la génération
identitaire à des bleus a déployé une
banderole hostile aux manifestants sur
l'une des façades d'un immeuble de la
place de la république en début de
rassemblement au ski à vous vous en
doutez a quelque peu agacé à les
manifestants un mot sur le cortège enfin
qui devait initialement rejoindre la
place de l'opéra mais la préfecture de
police a finalement décrété que le
rassemblement serait et statique enfin
sachez qu'à 19 heures on comptait 26
interpellations selon la préfecture de
police
merci et celle pour toutes ces
précisions et self argent direct de la
place de la république à apparaît idée